who do you think cheats more men or
women and do they cheat differently i
think we cheat differently i think men
cheat more okay but we definitely cheat
differently yeah like i feel like and i
know it's gonna sound bad but when women
cheat is worse yeah i was gonna say that
i i knew you guys would say that their
argument is because when the girl cheats
it's because she has feelings for him
he's providing something about that but
that's usually what it is it's just
about like it's about emotion it's about
on top of that like as a girl when a guy
sleeps with a girl he just sleeps over
you you can just like you can let your
sleep without never even work
when you guys that's not worse that is
not worth it if i got you just open up
your book you took
ah go on take over take over when you
cheat like if you were to cheat would
you cheat with someone ugly than your
boyfriend no there we go oh wait it
depends wait i'm sorry
depends on this no i was gonna say
so you're the first thing you see is
someone's attractiveness obviously but i
think if someone's not better looking
than your boyfriend necessarily but he
provides you with something else